so when i showed up in baltimore a
couple of days before july 1st
i mean it still wasn't crystal clear to
me that i could go
you know two days without sleeping stand
in an or for eight hours at a time
all those sorts of things now that's one
of the things the sleep deprivation
because people always
obviously i take a lot of flack
because i don't sleep a lot and and the
sleep deprivation
so what did that low what's that like
when you're going through your residency
and you're just saying i mean
there's days where you're going 24 48
hours no sleep
and how'd that affect you what did you
think of that what do you think looking
back at it
what's your opinion of it now well you
know when i decided
that that i was going to go into surgery
i mean i i always i'm pretty uh insecure
in general most people don't necessarily
appreciate that on the outside but
always thinking i don't know if i've got
what it takes here how do i figure it
out and so my
my whole mo in life is test the system
hard so when i was in medical school
still deciding this
i figured well every thursday night i'm
gonna pull an all-nighter
in my room standing up not allowing
myself to eat
sleep drink pee do anything
and i'm gonna stand at my desk for eight
hours and practice suturing
you know sort of try to mimic what it
would be like to be in an operating room
all night
not being able to go pee not being able
to drink not be able to do this thing
and so i had a little bit of confidence
go you know i figured okay i can do this
like i can pull an all-nighter once a
week that's you know not that that's a
good thing to do but it was like kind of
a confidence thing right
so then you show up but there's no
preparing you for what you're in store
for
now i got to point out this is not the
way it is anymore so in 2000
i want to say like four um
it's almost like labor laws came in
exactly a whole bunch of laws came in
that we could spend hours talking about
how it turns out the laws haven't
they haven't fixed the underlying root
problem but nevertheless a whole bunch
of work requirement hours stuff got
fixed right so you couldn't work more
than 80 hours in a week or 88 depending
on if your program had an exemption
and you couldn't work more than 24 hours
consecutively and stuff like that
but by the time those laws really kicked
in i was already gone
and and so i don't really know what it's
like today but i would
imagine it's um it's
less demanding from a sleep deprivation
standpoint
but at the time there were no such rules
and
you were at the sort of every second
every third or every fourth night call
but then your post call day you would
still work so
our mutual friend kirk parsley of course
is how we met this is one of his
favorite stories about me
because he loves this story because it's
so crazy
so this is july
of 2001. so i am one month into being a
doc right and i'm on an every third
night call
rotation at this hospital called bayview
which is
about five miles from what we call the
mother ship which is hopkins
and it's out in like east baltimore it's
in a real crappy part of town not that
there's it really i mean
i hate saying this but there aren't that
many good parts of town at least back
then in baltimore
um and uh
so i'm uh so i show up on a monday at
five o'clock in the morning
so i slept in my own bed sunday night so
monday morning i show up at five
to round we do our whole thing and
that night i'm supposed to go home so
that's my off couch called your swing
day
you show up at five you'll be home by 7
pm that night
if all goes well so you worked your you
know 14 hours
and then you sleep in your own bed and
then you get to come back the next day
and then you're going to be on call
so so we're rounding that afternoon
so and the uh what the the one of the
senior residents says hey
so and so didn't show up for their shift
in the er the
the er always staffs one surgical
resident full-time
and this guy just didn't show up and
she's like and it's a 7
p.m to 7 a.m shift can you cover it
and you know this would be like if you
asked the most junior guy
you know to do something like he he he'd
be kicking his own ass to say yes like
he couldn't wait
to do that right so i was like hell yes
i will do
that so then i go down to the er and i
work
all night seven to seven and then the
next morning is now my on call day
so now i'm 7am cranking away
until that night and then i'm up all
night on call
so and then it's now wednesday
and it's my post call day and i'm there
till
5 or 6 p.m so i've basically been up
from about 4 a.m monday
and it's now 5 or 6 p.m wednesday
and i get in my car to drive home and i
have to
make it i have to go down this miserable
street called eastern avenue
to hit the 83 to drive up to my place
and i'm driving along eastern avenue
which is like
red light after red light after red
light or stop sign or whatever
and every time i'm at a stop light i
fall asleep
my foot pops off the clutch and i stall
like i am
so tired i can't even
you know handle like the gradual you
know easing off the clutch and the gas
just to move up and up and up i can't do
it
so finally in one moment of lucid
clarity i'm like
you can't get on the freeway you're
gonna die
so i was like what's the solution i was
like you gotta get over and take a nap
so i pull over my car on the side of
eastern avenue right in front of this
park
called patterson park which at the time
i don't think i fully understood that
that was an open air drug traffic market
so i got out but here's the best part
sorry the logical thing to do would have
been just been stayed in the car and
take a nap
but i was like you know i haven't seen
the sunlight in like days and it's the
sun is still out like
i'm gonna go nap in the park so i get
out of the park i'm in green scrubs that
are covered in
you know blood stains because i was too
dumb to not change i
go lay down in the park i take my pager
off and i clip it
to my neck and i set the alarm to like
go off in one hour
you know so like 7 pm it'll wake me up
and i'll feel perfectly rested and i'll
be able to drive home
so i lay down in middle of patterson
park and the next thing i know i wake up
it's like
one in the morning two in the morning
there's needles everywhere there's i
have like
bites on my arm that look like they're
from rats because they're like nothing
i've ever seen before like these bites
all over me
and i'm just thinking myself like how
did i not get killed here
like the only thing that prevented me
from dying was how ridiculous the sight
was
you know if something's so strange like
nothing you know so
i was like god damn it man so i get back
in my car and drove home and
when i tell parsley that story he loves
it because he's like that's the classic
example of how
complete deprivation of sleep impairs
your judgment
um so you know there were a couple
stories in residency where i had to do
like those three night back to back to
backs
another time it happened i remember was
an o5 do you feel like though okay
driving a car is kind of boring right
stop lights but when you're really tired
but then all of a sudden something
happens like
boom i feel like when that happens i
feel i can lock on
there's almost no amount of sleep
deprivation that will stop me from
functioning and getting something done
that's important
on task on time absolutely is that true
does that mean
yeah i know i think i think an
adrenaline rush in the moment can
provide any amount
of clarity and focus that's necessary
the problem is very few things are life
or death that way
now in your world there were plenty of
things but in my world not and this is
the actual story i was gonna tell was
in uh probably my third year
uh i think it was my third year um
i was the same same sort of deal i ended
up covering for somebody and then
covering for two people and two
consecutive
nights and then it was my turn so that
was like three straight nights of not
sleeping
and it's the middle of the night and
this guy comes in the er who's
you know got a really diseased
gallbladder and in retrospect it should
have never come out that night but
a lot of times the dirty little secret
is surgeons want to operate at night
because they can get better or
time electively as opposed to waiting
the next day if it's not emergent so
sure enough we're in the middle of the
operating room doing a laparoscopic
gallbladder removal
at two in the morning when we don't
really need to be there two in the
morning we could have
slept and done it the next day um
and sure enough so so in a lab removing
the gallbladder is a two surgeon
procedure
so there's the main surgeon which
because we're teaching hospital i'm the
main surgeon i'm actually doing the
operation and then there's the attending
who's holding the camera and retracting
for me so i'm you know like i'm doing
this
and yeah that's a stimulating activity
but of course i've done a hundred of
them so it's not that stimulating
well i can't stay awake and i finally
somehow managed to fall asleep on this
patient like i
face plant into the patient wow luckily
it was laparoscopic so i didn't
contaminate the surgical
but so even something as stimulating as
surgery
right because look if the guy's aorta
was bleeding right right
i'm sure i would have guessed that yeah
exactly but all you're doing is falling
out
yeah bladder is no big thing yeah yeah
it wasn't stimulating enough to overcome
three days of sleep debt
did you do did you figure out any tricks
any
you know for instance i can't when i was
going through seal training and even my
whole career and even to this day
i take these i take little power naps if
i'm feeling that tired
i elevate my feet and i sleep for like
six to eight minutes
and it totally recharges me did you do
you take power naps
no aside from your power now there's a
park that lasted seven hours it almost
got you killed
i do i once took a power nap in my car
again same thing i was like
it was like eight o'clock at night i got
to the pool
i had a rule which was after you left
the hospital you never went home
because i knew if i went home i wasn't
gonna leave so i would always go from
the hospital
to the gym or the pool or whatever i was
doing and on this particular night i get
there it's eight o'clock at night
i am so tired i'm nauseous like the
thought so you didn't want to go home
just because you knew you'd go
don't go to sleep and you didn't want to
go to sleep because you've been awake
for three days why didn't you
why did you want to go and fall asleep
well because i you know it's really
funny a good friend of mine who again
a couple years ahead of me gave me
interesting advice whether it was right
or wrong i don't know he said look
you're going to be tired no matter what
in residency
don't stop doing all the other things in
your life because you'll still be tired
now i don't know that was the right
advice but i took it i heard that advice
and
my view was i'm going to continue to
work out every day i'm not on call
i'm going to you know do all the stuff i
want to do and unfortunately sleep
always took the brunt of it
so yeah so it would be to the pool and
so same thing i got there but on this
particular night i was so
tired i was so nauseous like i couldn't
suppress the desire to vomit
and i was like i'm not gonna i can't if
i puke in the pool they'll kick me out i
won't get to swim it's just not gonna be
worth it so i was like
just sit here for like 30 minutes
and take a quick nap so same thing took
the pager out which normally could wake
me up
clip it here and it was freezing because
it was like the winter so i
left no it wasn't cold but i remember i
wanted to leave the radio on
like a dumb ass so the car is off so
alternator's off
radio's on well you know how the story
ends i wake up at two in the morning
battery's dead i'm in the middle of the
parking lot i can't you know
had to call my girlfriend to get jumper
cables to get me out
that's a one that girlfriend went on to
become my wife by the way
um so short answer no i didn't have a
great strategy i did have
a friend who and i never tried this but
he told me he would put coffee grounds
in his eyelids and apparently it hurts
so much that you couldn't close your
eyes
you know that's i mean i would not that
but i've told people this all the time
too you know do
do a little bit of physical exercise if
you're super tired that definitely
picks you back up there's got to be some
reality or some scientific reason for
that
happening that's another thing you can
do